uh okay there was a complete
total softball pandering brown nosing
interview that donald trump did
on fox news with sean hannity on
thursday night
let's look at some clips we'll jump
right into it the sort of framework here
was
donald trump doing a media tour because
of the death of radical right-wing radio
host rush limbaugh reminder rush
limbaugh
celebrated the death of ruth bader
ginsburg
celebrated the deaths of aids victims in
the 90s not a good guy
trump calling in and hannity starts in
with you know
mr president sir it was such a great
idea to give rush limbaugh the
presidential medal of freedom how did
you come up
with such a great idea total suck-up
let's take a listen a true original
joining us now on the phone is president
donald trump
mr president i know that the honor of
his life
came from you and what that medal of
freedom meant to him
i know the behind the scenes story i
know
and i know who made the first call of me
anyway was matt drudge and
and jared kushner and um
and i know you made your decision and
with melania
there in about five seconds and you said
that's a great idea
tell us about it well it was an idea
that
we had that a lot of people suggested to
me frankly a lot of great
people of our country largely
republicans it was an amazing night
because the republicans
went wild and the democrats sat there
but they all respected
rush and i think it was you know one of
the great honors of his life
presidential medal of freedom it's a big
deal
and he uh he was very honored by it
and he was a great gentleman just like
mark said i i listened to mark
and you know mark is so terrific but you
know he said he's
special and rush was really special he
was a very special guy
you've said irreplaceable and it's true
he's irreplaceable
again trump deciding that the thing
he gave rush was the thing
rush was the most honored by trump needs
that to be true
for his own narcissism and he keeps
repeating that the right
loves rush and the left respected rush
i don't know anyone on the left that
respected rush limbaugh
i don't know anyone on the left who
would have respect for people who
celebrate the deaths
of people with aids or celebrate the
death of ruth bader ginsburg these
aren't mere political differences about
what the tax rate should be
where you say hey you know what we
disagree but i respect their point of
view
cheering aids deaths has nothing
respectable about it it is a bizarre
thing for donald trump to keep repeating
then hannity goes into even more sucking
up to trump
and trump again reveals that the thing
he really likes about rush
is that he supported trump that's all
trump cares about
you know this this side of you that i
know a lot of americans don't know
and i know many people that this story
holds true for
and i know in the case of rush and when
rush had his diagnosis
a little over a year ago i knew you were
calling him
regularly minimum of once a month often
much more than that
and you would always be checking in with
how are you feeling how are the
treatments how's everything going
and on i know you talked to him a lot
what were those conversations like
well it was interesting because i didn't
know rush at all as you know
i didn't know him at all until i had
gotten word
that from somebody that russia was with
us all the way he was
you know we have this guy who was so big
on radio
i i knew a lot about rush but i didn't
know him
and he was with me all the way and it
was sort of incredible i got to know him
after that
and he was much different actually you
know when you were
he was a very very um
uh i wouldn't say not outgoing
but he was very very warm he was just a
very warm
person and and you know when people got
to know him
i loved playing golf with russian i was
a i used to call him the bull because he
was actually a very strong guy
physically very strong guy
he hit the ball a long way when he hit
it he went a long way
and uh but you got to know him and and
he
and he loved this country and he loved
his wife
all the things trump says about rush his
ratings
his ability to do a radio show all that
stuff it would all be equally true
even if rush didn't support trump but
you and i know
that if rush was an anti-trump
republican who died
donald trump would not be doing this
donald trump doesn't have friends the
only thing that matters to trump is
are you a brown-nosing sycophant if so
i'll call you a friend
until you say the wrong thing and then i
say your you know uh
what's that lightweight as he often says
what you do
what you do for me and what you've done
lately is all that matters to donald
trump
let's look at a little bit more of this
here is sean hannity
with just a stunning brown nosing of
trump saying hey
here were russia's top issues these are
your issues as well
sir mr president trump on russia's show
today
i was listening um before i began my
radio program and
they played a segment of rush and in
that segment he said
if you took tapes of him when he started
in 1988 in syndication again nobody
thought that
that anyone can syndicate during the
daytime and be successful and
and he proved all the naysayers wrong
and if you look at where he stood
conservative justices liberty freedom
less government intrusion intrusion
less regulation less taxes lower taxes
energy independence secure borders uh
choice in schools the second amendment
free and fair trade
peace through strength sound familiar
because that's your agenda yeah that's
what you did he was right there
he understood it he got it and he's been
that way for a long time you know he
hasn't been somebody that's changed he
didn't go
from being a liberal to being a
conservative i mean he was there from
the beginning and he hasn't changed his
views hadn't changed very much
and his audience as you know better than
probably anybody the loyalty of his
audience was just incredible
staggering it's actually interesting and
sad how never changing your views
is seen as a badge of honor in some
circles on the right and on the left and
as i've said many times
having the exact same views for 50 years
likely means you're not learning
anything now i want to be really clear
i don't mean it's typical for say a 40
year old
not talking about anyone in particular
for a 40 year old
to have a complete political awakening
and 180 degree reversal where all of a
sudden they denounce everything they
stood for for 40 years
and say i was wrong all along and i'm
actually a right-wing nut okay
that raises red flags and it suggests to
me grifting
but what i'm talking about is saying
your views haven't changed at all
for 40 50 years as if it's a badge of
honor
look at how much we've learned about
life and humanity and the planet in 50
years
how could your views not change over
that period of time even
my views on many issues are modified
and adjusted and updated to account for
new things that we know
it's sad and it doesn't bode well for
the country
to see that praised as a badge of honor
just one more clip here hannity
explaining what might have been so
damaging to kaylee mcinanny listen to
this
your own kaylee mcinerney i mentioned
earlier tweeted that you know she was a
rush baby your dad would be listening in
the car
and it and it shaped her viewpoint
to conservatism uh and he did that for
so many of us
and so many around the country um i
i want to thank you um i appreciate you
being on the program i know i
i read your statement the other day and
i know you said in the
in the months ahead you have a lot you
want to tell us and
we won't do it tonight obviously but
when that when that time comes we're
looking forward to hearing
what your future plans are and um
what you are planning to do uh i have a
funny feeling
we're going to hear a lot more from
donald trump are my instincts correct
well there's a lot to talk about and our
country is a great place and
we're going to make it even greater as
the expression goes but
we have a lot to talk about but today's
all about rush
don't you think and so hannity mentions
there that
growing up as a little kid kaylee
mcinanny trump's former press secretary
would have rushed limbaugh playing in
the background because that's what her
dad listened to
you know that explains so much and that
is a cautionary tale
not to have radical right wing radio
playing in the background
when you're trying to raise
well-adjusted kids a real lesson in
parenting there
so trump back on fox news there it is
we'll see what role trump plays or
doesn't play in the republican party
going forward
and you can let me know your thoughts
about trump's return to the airwaves
i'm on twitter at deepakman most healthy
granola bars have sort of a bad
reputation they don't taste good
they don't fill you up they don't really
satisfy your craving
but our sponsor monk pack has changed
granola bars monk pack keto granola bars
are sweet and delicious soft and chewy
with only 140 calories 1 gram of sugar
2 net carbs which makes them work
beautifully
for the keto or low carb lifestyles
they come in flavors like coconut cocoa
chip
honey nut blueberry almond vanilla my
new favorite
i love these because i can grab one
anytime
it's quick it's a great snack forget the
dry
bland granola bars try monk pack keto
granola bars if you don't love them like
i do
they'll give you all of your money back
you'll get 20
off when you go to monkpack.com and use
the coupon code
pacman the link is underneath this video